there is something really interesting
going on in the still early stages of
the 2020 general election now I'm saying
general election because the Democratic
primary I guess we can say is well
underway now debates start in just a
couple of weeks but on the general
election side Donald Trump is only now
starting to even really campaign in
earnest you might remember that he filed
for re-election I think it was on
inauguration day in 2017 or soon
thereafter a right before right around
inauguration day 2017 Trump was
technically speaking running for
re-election in 2020 but he's not really
fully started his campaign and it turns
out the Trump campaign in the last
several weeks has taken some internal
polls of key battleground states and
Donald Trump is losing badly in some of
those and we've now learned thanks to a
really good New York Times report that
Donald Trump has been going out of his
way to demand that his staffers and his
administration suppress the negative
internal polls that they have taken for
example internal polls in Michigan and
Pennsylvania show that Donald Trump is
currently losing badly against any of
the hypothetical Democratic presidential
nominees important to understand these
are internal campaign polls they're not
public polls they're polls that the
campaign takes for their own purposes
Trump's campaign went and did polling in
17 states and when Donald Trump was
presented with the information he said
no no no say that we're doing well and
bury this data we don't want this stuff
getting out now unfortunately even
without the incipient leaks from the
Trump administration other pollsters
have also been polling in many of these
states and that information is now
public morning consult for example found
that registered voters in a bunch of
states are really negative on Donald
Trump only 39% of New Hampshire voters
approve of Trump only 42% of Wisconsin
voters approve of Trump Trump has a
minus 13 unfavorability versus
favorability rating remember
one Wisconsin narrowly in 2016
Michigan which Trump won in 2016 he's
minus 12 in terms of approval Iowa which
Trump won in 2016 he's minus 12 in
favorability Pennsylvania minus 7 he won
that in 2016
Arizona Trump is now minus 6 which he
won in 2016
Ohio and North Carolina Trump won both
he's minus 4 right now and even if you
look incredibly at some solidly red
states that Trump won in 2016 it's shaky
in Georgia Trump is only plus 1 in North
Dakota and Kansas Trump is only plus 1
Texas and Indiana Trump is only plus 3
in net favorability now I before I go
any further this tells us nothing about
how 2020 will go okay this doesn't mean
no matter where you vote that you don't
have to worry about voting for someone
other than Donald Trump but these
numbers combined with Trump panicking
and trying to suppress news of these of
this polling does tell us that number
one Trump is at least somewhat worried
number two Trump knows that to some
degree things are not looking great in
some of these key states and number
three this tells us Trump can easily be
removed in 2020 if voter turnout is what
it should be what it could be what we
want it to be in one sense though I
think it's good that Donald Trump is
reacting this way to negative polls if
Trump saw negative polls and said I need
to turn on my campaign game 100% that's
actually something he could do to turn
these numbers around if trump sees these
numbers and says let's suppress them
rather than let me campaign really hard
hopefully he just hangs out plays golf
watches Fox News ignores the polling
ignores the dissatisfaction from the
country tweets nonsense and that'll help
him be defeated but as Trump's
opposition it's really important that we
not be in any way satisfied just by
seeing this data into thinking that this
is going to be an easy one in 2020 by
any means
every state every voter should be
behaving as if your vote could be the
vote that hands your states either to
Donald Trump or to somebody else by
virtue of whether you choose to vote or
choose to stay home we don't know which
states are going to ultimately make the
difference it could once again be places
like Michigan and Wisconsin it could be
somewhere else the polling is
interesting
Trump's internal team finding that he's
losing Bigley in some of these states is
fascinating but none of it should be
used as a reason to do anything other
than vote in the primary vote in
November of 2020 period let me know what
you think about this latest state
polling in key battleground states I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman please follow me
there follow the david pakman show on
Twitter as well at David Pakman show not
surprisingly if you love learning new
things you probably want to check this
out the David Pakman show today is
sponsored by Skillshare and we're giving
you two entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy to use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video